- I didn't bring you here
just to sip some tea,
I wanted to spill some tea.
So I thought of a game.
I like to call it, "Sip It and Spill It"
and it's basically a very
sophisticated version
of "Never Have I Ever".
So I'm trying to keep something
very American and trashy, classy.
But for example, sip it and spill it
if you've ever locked
yourself in a bathroom
with a glass of wine
because you have children
and you just want a minute to yourself.
See, then I would take this bad boy
and I'd drink the whole thing.
- I'd have to drink that
with ya, I'm afraid.
(group laughs)
- I'm like, I just need,
- Sorry.
- "Mommy needs a minute."
- Yeah.
- Okay, I have one!
Sip it and spill it, if
you've ever rolled Easter eggs
while wearing a bonnet and dress.
(pensive music)
(chimes ringing)
- It's you!
(group laughs)
You wear a bonnet often?
(silverware drops)
Oh my god.
- It was Easter. My friend
said, "Put on a dress
and let's roll the Easter egg
down the hill," so we did.
- This makes you my
favorite person at the table
(group laughs)
once again.
- You said that twice.
- I know, once again.
- Okay, wait. Hugh, your turn.
- Sip it and spill it, if
you've ever snogged Brad Pitt.
- Snogged means kissed right?
- Kissed. Kissed.
- Are you about to sip your tea?
- Shall I show you?
Well I'm just going to, you know, just...
(chimes ringing)
Go Elizabeth!
- What is that story?
(audience applauds)
- Somebody had to.
- Somebody had to sacrifice.
- Well I did it as a paid job,
because we were on a set, acting in--
- What a beautifully paid job.
- Yes, indeed. There are
worse ways to earn a living.
- Wow
- So I was not complaining, but yeah.
He cut his teeth with me
I think, yeah as it were.
- Nice, did you teach
him how to snog well?
- I made him the man that he is.
- You made him a good snogger?
- Yes, he's learned everything from me.
- I always loved that y'all call it that.
- [Allen] Snogging.
- 'Cause it sounds not cool.